what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and we
finally have details about spider-man no
way home coming to streaming it looks
like sony has struck a deal with a
streaming service and i've been getting
a lot of questions about this because it
is not coming out on disney plus now
this isn't exactly a huge shock because
none of the other spider-man films that
are owned by sony and keep in mind the
spider-man homecoming trilogy is owned
by sony they do own the rights they made
a deal with marvel and disney to share
the prophets but they do on the rights
and no spider-man films that are owned
by sony are on disney plus so not a big
shock but let's talk about what
streaming service it is coming to the
timeline they've given us for when it
will hit the streaming service and what
this kind of means and if you're new be
sure to subscribe and hit the
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos now again
not a big shocker that it's not coming
right to disney plus like the other true
marvel studios property films but it is
kind of a shocker on what streaming
service it is coming to according to a
report from deadline.com a very
reputable news outlet they revealed in
an article about streaming services that
spider-man no way home is coming to
stars a subscription service that
doesn't really fall within the big
general subscriptions that everybody has
like disney plus netflix hbo max peacock
and it's interesting because this
article was not specifically about
spider-man being released on stars but
it was revealed through the article the
article was talking about star's ceo
jeffrey hirsch talking about how series
drive and retain customers more than
movies actually do they talked about how
big series drive retention of the
audience more than movies actually do
but then he said viewers gravitate
towards the app more for original series
but on the linear side people are
scrolling the channels and there are a
lot more movies than original series and
here's where it's revealed that
spider-man knowing home will be coming
to stars
it goes on to say a big film like
spider-man no way home which will hit
stars sometime over the next six months
is a tremendous boost providing you put
the right shows and content around it so
you can move customers that watch
spider-man into one of your originals so
essentially stars got spider-man no way
home streaming right so they could drive
viewers towards their other original
content that they're producing which is
smart on their end because a lot of
people will get stars probably just for
a month to watch spider-man no way home
now they say within the next six months
i'm going to say it's probably going to
be a little bit earlier than that
probably around the four month mark i'm
sure as they get close to it they're
going to start advertising it's coming
to streaming soon so when it comes out
we'll know soon enough but i've been
getting a lot of questions about what
this means for disney plus and marvel
studios's relationship with sony it
doesn't really mean anything in all
honesty marvel studios and sony have
already confirmed that they're already
working together again on the next
spider-man film and they specifically
said they are telling us that because
they don't want us to worry about
another marvel studios disney sony deal
so as far as the relationship between
sony and marvel studios and disney i
think it's fine they just had one of the
biggest movies of all time working
together spider-man far from home was
the first spider-man movie to hit a
billion i think sony realizes that they
need spider-man in the mcu and they need
marvel studios and of course marvel
studios isn't about to let spider-man go
anytime soon either i think this was
just a strict business deal nothing to
look too much into i don't think it
affects the relationship between the two
studios at all so spider-man should be
perfectly safe so i would expect
spider-man to hit streaming on stars
apparently within probably four months
at the maximum like they said six months
but i am curious because it's not been
said yet if you need a subscription to
actually purchase the film to watch if
you need a subscription will you be
getting the subscription to watch
spiderman knowing home let me know that
in the comments down below because i'm
very curious and don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all the latest news for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you